question is
can you turn a hoe into a housewife
why don't we go around you can start and
go with myself
it depends I think if the right man
is with the girl then she can be changed
into a housewife so it just all depends
on the individual the influence and the
circumstances that they've been through
for their life but I've been with girls
that may have had like numbers behind
them and I think that when they was with
me
I perhaps could have changed them into a
housewife but it's not every woman so it
could be just that particular person but
again it goes down to the individual
okay what is there um anything that a
girl can't come back from
it depends when you say that that's like
an open question
um is there anything a girl can't come
from it depends on the situation like
because I'm not really I'm not I don't
really judge people so I couldn't really
say that there's something that they
couldn't come back from but me
personally
as long as I don't really ask too much
questions about your past because once
you're with me I'm all about our future
so I don't really focus on what you've
done before me so as long as you're not
carrying on with the stuff you was the
stuff you was doing beforehand and it
wouldn't really bother me and this and
from where I'm not gonna have like maybe
a friend approach me and say yeah she
done this then I don't think it's really
going to be a problem but that's just my
personal perspective on it okay what do
you think me
um I think many have tried I don't
really think
I don't really feel like it's possible
um I believe that a leopard never
changed at sports so yeah
I'm I'm always a Believer
um
I feel like I've actually had
conversations with guys about this and
I personally haven't been in that boat
but I know a lot of girls do end up
being the housewife and a lot of us good
girls be like hey what did I do wrong
but I feel like some guys do feel like
when a girl does have enough experience
and they've gone through all of that
stuff like having to change guys or like
sleep around and I'm really really
trying for these girls
um I'm trying to play Devil's Advocate
um why but simply because everybody
deserves a second chance just because
you've done something when you're
younger doesn't necessarily mean 10 baby
mamas 10 babies I thought we were
talking about a woman
as long as it wasn't wow it was with me
because if it wasn't me I'd be like no
no it's before he matches okay
today I'm not really the type to really
go for the baby for others okay but for
them today yeah yeah no no no no maybe
from like 10 years from now maybe I
might look at the situation different
because I'll be a little bit older to
the point where like who do you exactly
think doesn't really have a child at
that age
why'd you say that because I don't
believe it as he whether you both don't
have kids seeing that does that's not
very common though about five or six or
seven of my my friends all in the same
boat no kids all professional all make
money or majority of people I know have
kids I'm like literally like I'm like
one of the few that don't I'm like that
goldfish in the tank was like how come
you haven't got kids yet why I don't why
do you not in that way but like I'm not
in a position to want kids yeah so I
just think that it's just probably where
you're looking because if you step out a
little bit further a lot of people
actually don't have kids or they don't
have baby moms or or they lie 50 of
women that hit 30 are single and
childless actually
oh they they're childless
for the people that I know to my
knowledge I'm going from what I know
yeah I don't mean they didn't kill you
yeah
I just know a lot of people like so you
might feel like somebody doesn't have a
child or they have a child and they
didn't know they had a child
okay
um
why don't you go
uh turn her home to a housewife no
why not
I think it depends on your definition of
a housewife but if you're talking in its
traditional way I would say no I think
too much experience
a lot of negative ones I think for
someone who would fit the definition of
a hoe I don't think I think by then
they're just damaged goods but what is a
hurt though yeah yeah that's a good
question that's my next question so why
don't you two answer and then we'll talk
about that
my definition of a hero is a girl has
stepped around a lot indiscriminately
um
I couldn't necessarily put a number on
it but I'd say
a girl who's not really been concerned
about whether she's got any connection
with the guys that she's been sleeping
with she's just been having a good time
racking up the body count
I would consider that to be a whole okay
yeah I feel that you can easily change
to one as all you need is probably just
a change of culture
because that's what you'll have to do
first thing when you change your culture
and stay somewhere else
so you do you think you can turn a home
into a housewife definitely for the time
being for sure
I like that optimism for for how long
a lifetime not lifetime but definitely
for the first two months
so you can turn into a housewife for two
months and then her her hoe comes back
she's like the streets are close to the
streets
okay now you can't turn the hole into
housewife
no no no
can you turn a hoe into a wife yeah it
happens all the time
because then if you look at all these
rappers they're doing all the time 24
yeah but if you look at rappers as your
idol then your idolizing celebrities we
don't look to rappers as as of course
but in terms of looking at people who
are turning hoes into Housewives they're
the majority of people who are doing it
how long do the um do the marriages last
probably not long because if you're
looking at Kanye West and kinky yeah
suddenly these are very bad examples to
use very bad examples then she's not
away yeah she's just a short term she
was a what she was a wife but she's not
a wife
that's true and maybe it depends on how
people interpret the definition of a hoe
then because then some people might feel
like certain things like women have done
in their life that's that's not really a
hero so yeah let's let's ask the man
what are you when
when does a girl become a hoe
a girl becomes a hoe when she has to
start lying about how many people she
slept with automatically you're holding
because from the moment you start lying
you're not even being true to yourself
um so that's when it starts so the
moment you have to start lying to
yourself and lying to other people your
whole so if she is honest and says 50
she's not a hoe oh no she's still a hoe
but she's just an honest hole
[Laughter]
we respect the honest ones as well yeah
no I'm still not gonna wipe her but I
respect the honesty so here's the thing
I mean we said before a woman has the
right to choose a woman has um the right
to wear what she wants a woman has
autonomy is sovereignty of her body a
woman can have consensual sex whatever
she chooses to be but those are the
woman's rights and men have our own
rights and doesn't mean we have to take
it for that so what we're trying to say
is women can do whatever they want we
don't judge you personally but us as men
have a certain standards and we don't
want to be of a woman that slept for
example my friend or a friend's friend
or something like that men and women see
sex differently
um a lot of women argue that they don't
and they treat it the same but you women
still don't mind seeing a guy that sees
a lot of other girls where us man we
detest that but what what if like um
I feel like the reason why I'm I feel
like I'm standing for certain women is
because what if
their psychological problems what if you
are judging somebody from the cover of
what you see them as but they actually
are somebody that just deserves good
love what if it's somebody that is
willing to change their colors for you
I think that's a feminine point of view
because we always try to change man okay
but like from the man's point of view
it's like once you've lost your Purity
it's gone but okay so somebody could
judge me per se they might look at me
and be like okay I don't like the way
that she dresses I don't like her point
of views but if it was a thing where you
sat down and we was to have like a night
out just me and you as girls and I told
you about my past and the reason why
I've done certain things and like I'm
ready to like give myself to somebody
that I really trust and really love do
you not believe I deserve a second
chance I mean I think no one deserves
anything
fair enough I think you kind of it's
like what do you qualify for and so it's
it's if if you you know did certain
things in the past like I just think
you're eliminated from certain guys but
don't worry one of three Mana virgins
are haven't had sex in the past year
there's someone so the girl there's
always someone I just think there's
there's a lot of honors on the men put
that we have to accept bad behavior
previous stuff we
no one is no one has to allow anyone's
previous history that's why if you've
ever done a crime in the past before
that you know if you go for a job some
jobs you can't go for and that's just
the way it is so I think a lot of times
women want us to
to be counselors and be psychotherapists
for their previous trauma which we had
no part in and that and that is fine
if the guy that once she's prepared to
take that but you shouldn't go into the
world thinking that anyone has to be
there to to fix any of your what I'm
trying to figure out as many of you know
I was just banned on Tick Tock and we
are demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible